when a lonely girl's imaginary friends
turned frightening Leo a young family's
dream becomes a nightmare attacked by
entities from beyond the grave they find
themselves helpless within their own
hormone as the violence escalates they
try in desperation to fight back and
understand what is happening around them
their search for answers leads to a
scientist who studies the paranormal and
a medium who claims to see the dead the
family soon discovers there is no place
to hide
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen it is the
first show of October and it's episode
59 yeah another haunting episode yeah we
thought we hadn't done one in a while so
you know I was about time we had to get
back to that and like I said I kind of
wanted to use October to kind of do some
spooky stuff and ghost stories yeah yeah
yeah spooky empires at the end of the
month yep that's right and we're gonna
be there it's the 27th 28th and 29th and
we're actually gonna be hosting the sick
and twisted panel on Friday night at 9
p.m.
yeah and today's episodes about mr.
Gordy yes the very the very famous and
it was actually not just a haunting
episode it was also on unsolved
mysteries actually I think yeah that's
how it started out and it was also the
basis for a Hollywood horror film
Haunting in Connecticut 2
ghosts of Georgia right yeah yeah
whatever like people don't know it but a
haunting actually started off as like
two of these feature-length kind of
pilots first one was haunting in Georgia
and the other one was Haunting in
Connecticut and that gave birth to a
haunting as a series and I thought we
had those on our haunting compilations
and they weren't there
we actually had to go online to find him
I don't think they sell those too well
they might but I couldn't find that I
mean they weren't on YouTube we had to
watch them somewhere else yeah if you
get season one Omaha I thought they were
great as a collection but then yeah yeah
cuz I remembered it I said they must be
on that our season one discs and they
weren't there but they're good they're
two really good episodes yeah okay so
before we get into that we have to do a
bunch of shoutouts my newest book the
faceless villain which is a true-crime
compilation of unsolved murders from
1900 to 1959 first in the three-volume
series will be out very very soon like I
said the print version is done the eBook
version is done I'm just recording the
audiobook version so the print in the
e-book will be up first and then
probably the audio book will follow up
and if you're gonna want a free audio
book because I usually they usually give
me 25 free codes to send to people who
promise to write a review for the audio
book then
when the book comes out let me know
it'll probably be like three weeks from
now so don't get excited but you know
what I mean
so say just let me know when you patrons
will get first dibs on the fries yeah
yeah okay so speaking of patreon we have
three new patrons this week Michael
Joanie and Arif thank you very much yeah
welcome to love l'amour and we also had
a PayPal donation from one of our
YouTube listeners Dean thank you very
much thanks the awesome yes and if you
would like to do our patreon as you know
a monthly donation or whatever just go
to our patreon page which is 13 o'clock
podcast or if you would like to make a
one-time donation if that's more how you
roll then you can go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast.com slash
WordPress something like that I always
forget and there's a little link on the
side that says donates PayPal so you can
just click on that yeah some people
don't like patreon yeah which is fair
enough so we have another option there
if you'd like to support the show and
don't want to get involved in patreon
then you can just do a one-time PayPal
donation that's totally fine and much
appreciated and we also had our first
successful patreon Google hangout yes
this past weekend we had it on September
30th yeah we met Paul and we met Paul
one of our UK listeners so that was very
awesome we kind of talked his ear off I
hope we didn't bore him to death yeah my
head was killing me because I came down
with the flu
some kind of weird 24-hour flu that I
had on yeah first I was thought I was
gonna have to do the Hangout by myself
but then Tom sucked it up but yeah my
eyeballs were killing me and let's see
the only other shadow I have to make oh
ok so remember last week I think I
mentioned this last week for our
Halloween episode we wanted to do reader
ghost stories they don't necessarily
have to be ghost stories they show you
reader creepy stories so like something
true and creepy that happened to you or
someone you know and I've only got one
so far and it's kind of short so if
anybody wants to hear their true creepy
story read or summarized on our special
Halloween episode then drop me an email
at grave cake at gmail.com I'll put that
in the share description if we
have enough or you know the best ones or
whatever we'll put them on the show and
it should be kind of fun I hope
yeah so we'll see how that goes now
let's get to a haunting like I said we
hadn't we realized because we've been
doing a lot of listener requests because
we've been doing a lot of listener
suggestions we realized that we hadn't
actually done a haunting SEPA sewed our
review in a long time and even though
we've done like a lot of our favorite
ones you know like record man and all
those other fun yes so easy man so they
even mentioned the raccoon ah yes thank
you for the shout out on Twitter that
yeah that that really did crack me up so
thanks for that
for it was very cute it was like a
drawing of a of a raccoon that said
you'll never fight so yeah that that was
very that was cool but we decided to do
this one which actually is a pretty
famous case freely in Georgia and in the
United States and like I said it's had
like lots of adaptations now this is
generally called the Wyrick haunting
because that's the last name of the
family that it involved or a lot of
people know it because of mr. Gordy yeah
it also involves a pretty famous pair of
psychologists yes that's right yeah and
I add some credibility to the case it's
a very credible story I think as far as
haunting episodes go yeah I mean their
best walk and I believe there was even a
book about the case I'm not sure who
wrote it but I think it was called the
veil and it was about Heidi Wyrick who
was the kid that originally started
seeing yeah the ghosts at the beginning
of the story but if you see the episode
as tom was talking about before when a
haunting started it actually didn't
start out as a series per se it actually
started out as two two hour specials
that were just like one offs and one of
them was The Haunting in Connecticut
which was about those snedecker
snedecker family yeah and they kind of
what they did paranormal witness they
made a movie about that [ __ ] and all's
and I'm not even gonna go into that
because I think that might be I think
that story kind of probably largely
[ __ ]
which story well the snedecker one oh
it's Nana Kyrgyz yeah it's very a
medieval free weirdo you know we grew up
with that case we're hearing them yeah
because I remember seeing them on like
Geraldo I Jesse Raphael and all that
back in the day it was an intriguing
case beam's didn't get down to the
bottom of it yeah that was the one if
you don't remember that was the one that
was set in the old funeral home right
and there was supposedly all kind of
funeral home accoutrements in the
basement and all yeah phantom but [ __ ]
keys as you were running down the road
remember that they did not mention that
on the episode she got bad she got mad
on a talk show I mentioned that yeah
healed it out at the audience that it
was raping her handily as she was
running down the road an invisible force
that's right she only said it once which
if that was happening and I think I'm
sorry but it's just it's just such a
funny mental engine how do you put that
in a movie how do you illustrate oh I
can see it now wouldn't be scary anymore
it would just be hilarious yeah because
you can't make that scary yeah but I
remember her saying it they're like what
but works by the abyss right now people
like what the hell's butthurt it's a
long story had to do with me and my
friends playing a video game called
wrath Stannis 711 back in like 1986 and
yeah and Wrath stammers kind of like
Conan when you'd fall on spikes ego it's
long story so yeah he would make any my
friends invented that term but [ __ ]
kitsch because it that's it sounded like
the noise being on that thing what up is
that ridiculous
say that's a so that's how we say nice
thing about parking but yeah so the
static ER case I don't know but the
other original haunting documentary the
two-hour documentary was you know less
bullshitty I think and it was based on
the wire case and the case of mr. Gordy
now I guess these two standalone shows
were so
successful exciting was the Discovery
Channel other yeah we're so successful
that they decided to make a whole series
out of it and obviously you know how
that went because that [ __ ] yeah those
two pilot episodes actually really got
my attention when they came out I was
like man these are really good yeah he
came out with a serious and you know
this series was launched on the back of
those two pilots and it was yeah you
know everybody knows what was you know
the first couple seasons of The Haunting
we thought was the best yeah because it
didn't go over the top lady started to
get a little over the top and it's
starting to kind of come across as that
they were gonna take any case any case
they could get their hands on and make
it the fantastic next best case there's
always a problem with that yeah they I
think they started feeling like they had
to the last right so it's like they have
to make it create so now like every
single one is flying demons and
werewolves not to say that those cases
are false just some of the cases are
better than others and let's come on
let's admit to that some of the cases
yeah the interesting thing about the
original and I don't remember
the the original snedecker documentary
but the interesting thing about this one
was that you know how later on on a
haunting you know they did actor
reenactments right yeah well this one
they did reenactments but they used the
actual people yeah and let me mention
something before you get those first two
pilots are not available on YouTube and
evidently are not available on CD as far
as we know but they're on dailymotion if
you want that's where that's where I saw
them I found them right so yeah it's in
two parts somebody put it up but oh yeah
what is it you had to Google something
like I put a haunting in Georgia 2009
and it came up yeah and to possess why
cuz I went got screenshots and stuff
like that cuz I thought we had it on
yeah they're actually pretty good copies
yeah good old dailymotion oh yeah like I
said the interesting thing is they still
do the reenactments of all the stuff
that happened but they use the actual
people yeah which is that was pretty
creative like yeah they didn't use that
I think the only one obviously that they
had to use actors for was like the kids
because now kids
around and stuff like that so you know
for the little kid that played Heidi
that wasn't your the actual kid right
the girl was a teenager when they filmed
it okay here's what happened in the case
now the family is Lisa and Andy Wyrick
and at the time that they moved to this
little house in Ehlers lrz Ellerslie
something like that Georgia they had a
daughter named Heidi
now I'm it's weird because like the
different things say different she was
either three or five she was you know a
little girl
it was 88 or 89 but they moved to this
house now the house see some sites say
oh it was mysteriously abandoned by the
former owners but then other sites say
well it was just abandoned because the
people didn't pay their mortgage
whatever they just you know they
couldn't afford it anymore and they just
took off and left it and when they left
it it was apparently in kind of bad
shape okay so I guess the Wyrick Scott
it sort of cheap now it was in a pretty
rural area right I've only been to
Georgia a couple of times so I'm not
real sure his rural yeah I mean other
than Atlanta in Savannah but that's why
the Walking Dead happens yes they
apparently bought this house for cheap
and they got it renovated now nothing
weird happened during the renovation
apparently and I don't really know how
long that took but they had lived there
for a little while and then their little
girl Heidi started saying that she was
seeing an old man that was coming to
play with her yeah like she would be out
in the backyard messing around and she
would come back in for lunch or whatever
and your mom's like hey what were you
doing out there and she's like oh I'm
playing with my friend mr. Gordy mr.
Gordy yes she called him and in the
episodes for it's really great how they
do the kind of reenactment they had this
old guy yes kind of friendly looking guy
kind of looks like you know my old
principal or something
my school how you doing mrs. Heidi would
you like to be on a swing with me
[Music]
kind of kind of draws the in on the
episode what the hell is going on yeah
but so Heidi she described this man as
like an older man with silver hair with
a black suit and shiny black shoes now
on the show they shared him as
bareheaded but I think she said he had a
tall hat on okay when she saw him and
she said that he would push her on this
wing and then he was really nice and
stuff like that
obviously the mom is like not down with
this idea cuz she thinks this is an
actual creepy old pet oh that's lurking
around the neighborhood like yeah hey
little girl let me push you in this wing
yes play with your dolls she called her
husband yeah she calls her husband and
says hey there's some weird happened
perfect you are pushing her little girl
on the way he comes running on back home
in his truck and jumps right into his
rifle cabinet pulls out his 45 and he's
searching the neighborhood for this guy
yeah he's like running around in the
yard with his dad or everything I'm
calling you and of course it's really
strong Georgia accents involved you know
yeah yeah they're very is like I you
know I'm from the south so yeah you know
how that man he's asking her did about
my little girl so yeah so he's running
around the house of this guy and they
can't find anything now as the little
girl keeps saying oh playing with mr.
Gordy and playing mr. Gordy and
sometimes the mom will hear the little
girl like in her bedroom talking to
somebody and sometimes she'll be like
hey can I have extra cookies or can I
have an extra sandwich and stuff and she
takes him in her room because therefore
mr. Gordy right here but then the mom
goes in there and she sees a little girl
and she's talking to nobody she's
talking to like a empty chair yeah so
for a while as you would you think well
the kids just lonely and she has an
imaginary friend a mr. Gordy right and
that's kind of how it stayed I mean I
think the parents were kind of worried
but you know everyone was like oh you
know kids they ever met you it's fine
just don't worry about it so they
actually decided to humor the kid you
know like oh okay here's another cheese
sandwich for mr. Gordy and how's mr.
Gordy doing today and stuff like that
now there was also a day when the little
girl was sitting in the living room and
heard a knock on the door and she went
to answer it and she
says that there was a man standing there
who had blood all over his shirt and a
bandage around his hand yeah she asked
who are you you know he said I'm mr.
Cobb he said his name was Khan Oh like
that kind of guy
[Music]
not that Khan boy they butchered that
poor Star Trek
I know but Khan cos that's what he said
his name was now Heidi did not appear to
be afraid of these dudes I mean she goes
back inside and the mom is like so who
was that knocking at the door said oh
it's a man with blood on his shirt and
he says his name is Khan moms like what
yeah and then she grabs a butcher knife
and runs out there it looks around the
house and she doesn't see anything
either right so she's like okay that
must be another imaginary person well my
kid is kind of weird yeah so this goes
on for like a couple of years and they
just assume that the kid is seeing
imaginary things they try to do things
like oh they get her a dog and stuff
like that I remember that yeah yeah you
know so she won't be so lonely and
things cuz I guess there wasn't you know
it was kind of out in the middle of
nowhere and there weren't a lot of a lot
of others yes for her to play with and
this dog ends up freaking out at one
point yeah that's what yeah that's later
on though so they've been there for a
for a couple of years in the interim
Lisa the mom she had asked around the
neighborhood and said do you guys know
anybody did mr. Gordy or anything like
that and no one did but then her sister
Joyce buys the house next door to them
now this house was purchased from a
woman who she was an older woman and
she's um she's on the haunting episode
and she was an older lady there so I'm
assuming she's probably dead by now
she said her parents had owned it and
her grandparents and Onan so her family
had been living there for a really long
time now she happens to have an old deed
from the house and she shows it to Joyce
and Joyce sees the name James Gordy on
the bottom of the deed and she freaks
out and she freaks the [ __ ] out because
she's heard you know her niece talking
about hanging out with mr. Gordy and
she's like what the [ __ ] so she says to
the lady that had owned the property
she's like who's
boy she said oh you know he was a friend
of the family he was this nice old man
he was like a real estate agent or real
estate developer since they didn't own
this property and a bunch of other
properties said he was the executor of
my mother's will like he took care of
all her legal shed and everything that
he kind of took care of her when she was
dying and stuff like that and she's like
well where is he now she's like oh he
died in 1974 yeah he's been dead for a
long time so Joyce is like holy [ __ ] I
have to go tell Lisa about this [ __ ] so
she goes to her sister's house next door
says check this out
she's like that's a real guy yes except
he's dead yeah yeah then it comes to lay
like they take the little girl to see
the guy's grave it doesn't really I mean
they said when they took her to the
cemetery she knew right where his great
was like she went right same way she
went right - and she can't read and she
couldn't read but she yes but she knew
that's who's great but he also ended up
showing her a photograph well now the
first thing they did was the lady the
older lady that had owned the proper
whose family had owned the property next
door that Joyce bought she brought over
a whole [ __ ] ton of old photographs just
to see if the little girl Heidi would
recognize any of the people now she's
going through the pictures and she picks
out a group photo and she points to one
old man she says that's Caan okay yeah
and he had his arms crossed it was like
an older guy and the old lady said
that's my uncle she's like his name is
actually lon
long bachelor okay but she said that
when he was a teenager he got his hand
caught in a cotton gin and it got cut
off
right so pasta explaining why he had
blood on it and a bandage on his hand
when the little girl saw him run so that
was pretty freaky yeah you know so all
this shit's been going on and they're
like okay well I got through a time
where she actually yeah but that was
later I was later that was later on that
was after the pair of psychologists came
and everything like okay I'm getting
ahead of the story yeah that's what you
see I have an outline and you guys you
just keep messing oh also also it should
be noted that lon aka Khan had died in
1957 so he had been dead for an even
longer time now I don't think that Heidi
saw him a lot I think she they just
mentioned
show that she saw him one time just that
one time but she might have seen love he
came through the door yeah have you got
creepy that would be kind of creepy but
like I said the little girl really
didn't seem that upset and they talked
to her like she was a teenager when the
haunting episode was made and they
talked to her later on about seeing the
ghost and everything and it didn't seem
to alarm her she said because I can tell
if they're good or bad or whatever so
right so I'm pretty sure that the
audience now gets the drift and if they
haven't seen this episode this girl this
little girl can see ghosts yeah ghosts
of the Dead of people that were
associated in that area right but for a
long time she seemed to only see good
ones
then came 1993 and Lisa had another
daughter named Jordan she had a baby and
after the baby was born then Heidi
started to see another ghost and this
one was scary now she said this one she
couldn't see who they were but she said
it was just like a black figure like in
a hooded coat like she said she couldn't
say their phrase so it was just like a
hood over it all the time and she said
this one she felt was hostile yeah and
she said that you know whatever she
would see it it would get really cold in
the room and stuff like that and in the
TV episode evidently based on what
they're showing she's seen it in the
daytime too yeah
I mean and she kept seeing it like all
the time but yeah she would see it in
her room she would kind of see it all
over the place a couple weeks after
Jordan was born
Heidi wakes up in the middle of the
night and her face hurts so she runs
into her parents room is like Oh
someone's some woke me up my face hurts
and I'm scared and stuff like that and
they look at her face and there's the
tell-tale three scratch marks on her
face so it's three kind of like the lock
on the door and mouth Mountain bulbs you
guys case yeah yeah three scratches yeah
maybe four is not as convenient it's the
minimum amount of scratches you need to
make it look like a claw mark I guess I
guess so because like I said if you're
gonna make a claw mark then you'd
probably just like put your pinky and
thumb like tuck it into your with a
little scratch marks and cats and other
kind of animals is it three or is it
four I don't know well kid you don't
think I either yeah the strike was yeah
weird okay but so yeah so she has leaves
little scratches
face now because you know before they
had kind of been used to her seeing the
nice ghosts and everything like that but
this was kind of a new phenomena so at
first they just thought well she just
scratched herself in her sleep and a big
deal but then two nights later Andy the
dad he wakes up and he has three scratch
marks like on his side yeah like and
they're supposedly really deep and he
can they burn yeah yeah cuz he was
saying on the show he's just like you
should what did he said carry my fire
yes it's Jared burning - yeah so yeah so
yeah calamine lotion
they still make that but that's brace
moss on it
I would not spray I would not spray off
on it
maybe bactine yeah I'm not gonna spray
it off on a real real just sprays off on
it you get burned you're gonna spray off
on it maybe that off because that's
something you have in the truck no I
already thought wd-40 that's pretty WT
for when your arm comes off just but wt4
else over it put some duct tape on okay
now okay now here's something that I
found on a written like online
description of the case that they
actually did not put in the show now
evidently Joyce's daughter you know who
was Lisa andis niece was over
babysitting Jordan the baby yeah now
apparently she hurt the baby choking in
her room so she runs in there to see and
she finds the baby with a ribbon knotted
a bunch of times around the baby's neck
and the baby's like suffocating oh that
wasn't in the absence no that wasn't in
the episode but I saw that like in a in
a later thing about the case weird maybe
that was in the book I don't know yeah
so she had to like quickly she had to
cut this little ribbon off now the
ribbon had come off of a teddy bear that
was in the crib but they said you know
there's no way that the baby could have
got this ribbon off of the teddy bear
and then dotted because they said it was
not in a bunch of times
like around the baby's neck so they are
attributing this to the scary dark
figure right now Lisa and anterior kind
of said oh well maybe we should move
because this is this [ __ ] is getting
serious and all this other kind of stuff
but after you know after a while they're
like you know this is our house and if
Heidi is seeing things and other people
in this [ __ ] is happening maybe it'll
happen to us wherever we go
so maybe we should stay here and try to
figure it out so to that end they would
and oh and there's also Lisa started to
hear things also like she would be
laying in her bed and she would hear she
said she heard - gravelly voices like
talking up near the ceiling and she said
she got the impression that they were
talking about her but she couldn't
understand what they were saying yeah so
they started to feel like this was maybe
a demonic presence you know and I think
they didn't really go into this much in
the episode either but on something else
that I read about the case they said
actually the family fled from the house
several times to like stay with
relatives or stay at a hotel or whatever
so it wasn't just a case where were
actually they probably should have put
in the episode because yeah it's not
like they didn't have time it was two
hours long that's kind of weird that
she's laying in bed and she's hearing
these gravelly voice is talking about
her she can't really tell what it is you
know and the ceiling
I mean I kind of had that happen to me
was my case I had to have heard her
voice and I ran yeah maybe maybe just
because she was older and being female
maybe it has some dude she just froze in
bed couldn't run anywhere yeah yeah it's
like sometimes you're kind of like you
don't want to move because you're afraid
what if I move in like some wish [ __ ]
happens its attention right yeah so
you're trying to just like pretend I'm
not here
well it was kind of that way when I was
laying in bed when I heard their
furniture Kandra across the floor
remember that first night there in that
house I just froze well yeah I put a dam
by rabbit right I mean I think some I
think that some people think that you
have
oh it's fight or flight like you're
gonna get up and run but honestly I
think probably 99% of people if they
were in that situation would freeze for
a second because you'd be like
oh [ __ ] what if something's in here I
don't want him to see me or I you know I
think that's a more naturally the first
time it kind of happened to me at
Mammoth it was like it's like I froze up
in fear I knew that something wasn't
right well because you could scent
because it'd be different if you thought
that someone broke in it was good wrong
or you were so yeah like that and then
the next day I was kind of embarrassed
or ashamed of my fear of it like how it
must have been my imagination yeah but
it wasn't you know but like I said
that's again a very calm yeah thank you
because you feel especially like in the
next day when it's you know the sun's
out and everything seems normal
you seem like oh well it's easy to say
it's easy to say oh well I just imagined
that yeah I'm stupid because I look at
the situation when I'm laying there in
that telephone receiver I hear it pick
up and fall had that not happened to me
and I heard somebody tell me that story
I'd be like man how to run out of there
looking back and I know it's not what
happened you just kind of like like this
like like a deer in the headlights
you're just like yeah okay check it out
now I I don't have and I know a lot of
people have you know night terrors and
things like that I don't usually have
that I don't usually even have bad
nightmares even though I write about
horrible things but um I have had one
instance of sleep paralysis in my entire
life and this is what and and I thought
it was real and this was when I lived by
myself in an apartment and I woke up and
I saw a man standing in the door of my
bedroom holding a bat like a baseball
bat that was poised and even though for
a few seconds I thought it was a real
person yeah I didn't get up I didn't
scream I didn't do anything I just laid
there and stared at it like frozen you
know what I mean but then I realized oh
okay I'm dreaming all right it's
paralysis or whatever they happen to
were a dream and reality you seeing
reality but there's like a dream
superimposed over the top that's kind of
what this was yes but it did it looks
real though I mean it looked like a real
man standing there like I couldn't see
his face or nothing but you know he
looked like a man standing there okay so
what we're gonna do we're gonna take a
break right now and when we get back we
will continue talking about the Wyrick
haunting and mr. Gordy and we might get
into the movie adaptation that I'm only
seen it once and it wasn't that great
but we'll talk about it too because it
was a lot different than
showcase so we'll be back in just a few
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
hey 13 o'clock fans love the show but
don't have an hour to spare check out
our new list channel 13 o'clock in
minutes all the fun creepy topics of the
main podcast but in easy to swallow
bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day at this house is very much
haunted and will continue to be on the
dome a long time
okay so we're back talking about this
now like I said at this point it was
getting really bad now this they also
did not mention on the show but
apparently Lisa and Andy began to feel
like there were a lot of illnesses and
their families that they attributed to
this dark presence or which they
perceived as a demon and they had to
have a bunch of surgeries and they just
thought it was happening an unusual rate
so they did in tribute that to
supernatural causes and also like you
mentioned before their dog was
constantly freaking out and barking at
things that are that weren't there and
yeah one of the witnesses said that that
dog was barking into the kitchen and it
was just beside itself that's what she
said she said it was beside it though
she said it was showing all its teeth
and it was yeah and they were sitting
there trying to figure out what the dog
was barking at they never could see yeah
and then later that dog ends up not
vanishing and never coming but yeah
that's right the dog run ran away and
never came back because like [ __ ] that
house now I've come across that in
several cases of dogs freaking out in
poltergeist cases part yeah things that
weren't there chasing things that
weren't there and then bashing yeah dog
vanishes I still imagined an animal
can't deal with that well yeah it's like
what are they gonna do alright it's
funny because I make jokes about it but
like what our kitten will suddenly be
run around and she'll suddenly stop and
look up at the ceiling like really
intently I always tease her I'm like are
you looking at ghosts other goes up
they're always made me wonder what it
was that they were actually seeing are
they just seeing like a ball of maybe
infrared light or are they seeing I mean
I've always been curious I wish we could
kind of like tap into their little
brains and see if they're actually
seeing anything or maybe they're just
feeling something feeling a presence
kind of you know I felt a presence yeah
maybe they're feeling a presence and
feeling being watched from an area and
they're looking and they don't see
anything else either using them that's
maybe that's what's happening yes in my
poltergeist case have we everyone felt
like you were being scrutinized from a
certain direction yeah but there was
nothing there so maybe that's all it is
yeah that's that's probably pretty I
mean if humans feel that that I imagine
animals probably feel that they might
feel it even more yeah it might be more
pronounced right so at this point they
decided we're gonna have to do something
about this now to their credit unlike a
lot of the families that were on later
episodes they did not immediately go
running to the church they did later but
the first they went right to the top
pretty much they went to dr. William
role famous parapsychologists yeah
you've written a lot about yeah if you
if you've read my book the unseen hand
there is a bunch of cases that he
investigating that he's very cite he
does not believe in ghosts
he believes that anything paranormal can
be explained in a natural framework even
if it's nature that we don't understand
yet which is about the same kind of
viewpoint that I have I'm kind of a
mixture yeah and the interesting thing
too is that William rolls books case
studies and things like that that I read
when I was a teenager that's what gave
me the idea to do the unseen hand
because I wanted to do like a throwback
book kind of like that because I felt
like they weren't that many I think this
I think there's a scientific explanation
yeah but I also believe that possibly
the mind can survive or the
consciousness can survive death yeah
cuz I've had out-of-body experiences and
near-death experiences and that may be
perceived as a ghost yeah but that's
what it goes I guess you could say yes
right but I'm not saying it's
supernatural that might actually be a
natural phenomenon some kind of a
quantum consciousness or quantum soul
theory you know so I kind of put myself
an end up into a mixture category yeah
it's possible maybe someone can hold
themselves together long enough to
interact with the world and be perceived
as a ghost could also be that perhaps
the past could replay itself like a
recording I think they call it residual
yeah or the stone tape theory if you
prefer which was named after a British
TV movie right or it could be that some
some people can just tap into the past
and see the past which is actually when
um William roll came to investigate he
interviewed all the family members he
did all your standard parapsychological
things he you know he took readings all
around the house he and he was there
like in and out for a very long time him
and his assistants he came to the
conclusion he did not think the family
were making things up he didn't think
they were crazy or anything like that he
thought that it was probably a
combination of he did find some
interesting I don't think he found any
unusual electromagnetic readings but he
found some very unusual like high high
ion readings
that nature today ions can affect the
right hemisphere yeah it can cause
visions right so he was thinking that
maybe it was some kind of anomalous ion
thing that was causing hallucinations
and or that Heidi was psychic because he
does believe that people have natural
latent abilities and psychic powers and
can tap into various things or what that
she was accessing the past somehow and
reconstructing it in her mind so he
didn't believe that mr. Gordy was an
actual ghost who was still fiddling
around in the present he just believed
that she was reconstructing an image of
him from past things because it actually
was dr. role he actually got them in
touch with the TV show unsolved
mysteries with Robert Stack and they did
a show about that and that actually came
out quite a long time before the
haunting episode did haven't seen that
one I'd like this I don't think I've
seen that one either but he got them in
touch so they kind of you know
collaborated on that now the unsolved
mysteries show was able to locate a
picture of mr. Gordy and this was when
they they took a picture of mr. Gordy
and they mixed it in with a whole bunch
of other ones of dudes that looked like
that
similar to mr. Louie um and they showed
it to Heidi and she immediately said
that's mr. Gordy did you make him up out
of a lineup like without even hesitating
you know after that and after her
identifying you know the con lawn person
they probably thought she was somehow
accessing past people in the area yeah
you know like I said she didn't feel
like mr. Gordy or anything she always
felt like mr. Gordy was protecting her
and was protecting her from the other
spirits in the house and keeping them
from doing worse things right so like I
said William role came back a bunch of
times and studied it and that's kind of
she just he just thought well Heidi as a
psychic her mom he also thought her mom
Lisa had some psychic abilities and that
it kind of ran in the family yeah he
wasn't sure whether or not it was
something in the environment causing
psychic psychic phenomena in this family
or if it was something that was
inherited genetically yeah he kind of
unsure right he kind of said it could be
either thing and maybe both yeah or both
could be now after a while I think that
since the phenomena continued dr. role
also put them in
touch with a psychic wonder named Amy
Adams or Amy something it's a pretty
black-haired yeah girl she got the girl
she ended up getting her own show yeah I
forgot what her name was
I think it was Amy something like I want
to say Amy Adams like the actress cuz I
was like oh it's the same name as that
actress but yeah so she was on the show
too and she was playing herself in the
reenactment and then they were
interviewing her now evidently William
role sent the psychic to the house and
he said now you were not allowed to talk
to the family beforehand you were not
allowed to go to the house beforehand
you have to go to the house when the
family is not there and you're not
allowed to like you know research the
area or anything like that because he
wanted her going in cold so evidently
she did hmm
now she went into the house and even
though like the stuff she said was you
know kind of vague but she did say that
outside in the backyard
she felt a protector spirit which they
thought was mr. Gordy and inside she
felt something very hostile like a
faceless figure so what she said kind of
lined up with now I should say too that
the ghost of a little girl was also seen
in the house this was apparently seen by
Heidi it was seen by Jordan the younger
sister when she got a little bit older
and I believed that Lisa's sister Joyce
also saw this little girl and heard her
laughing yeah and even though Joyce said
she was creeped out by it because she
said the laugh sounded very creepy and
then she saw the little girl really
quickly but Heidi said that she had seen
the little girl too and that she wasn't
afraid of the girl like she didn't think
the girl was going to hurt him she also
said she heard an older woman laughing
outside the door of the bathroom while
she was taking a shower yeah that
happened later on so you know like I
said this house [ __ ] super on it
evidently either that or they're just
psychic people and they're thinking like
I said that in the past and reactivating
personalities yeah yeah maybe maybe a
quote-unquote ghost is mostly just kind
of like like imagine like a quantum
level computer program it's just stored
in the hard drive it's not happening
until you open that program yeah and a
psychic can open that program
all of a sudden that ghost kind of comes
alive and does a little demo yeah that
person may not be aware that ghost may
not be a real ghost am I just right an
image from the past yeah that's kind of
what I suspect it might be interactive
image you know almost kind of like AI
but it's not there it's not a it's not
an intelligent being yeah like you can't
like ask it questions like in the
present day and have this here some
people that have claimed to have gotten
together and just consciously will the
ghosts into existence of a person that
never lived and evidently it caused a
haunting that fit the description of
what they had imagined well and I think
and I've mentioned this on a lot of my
interviews that I did about some of my
poltergeist books too is that and and
you kind of think this too that it
especially in poltergeist kind of cases
I think there's an element of almost
like a feedback loop or like expectation
causing things to behave in a particular
like if you if you boot if you believe
that you want to see the ghost of George
Washington you might get the ghost of
George Washington but that's not George
Washington yeah that's not actually
George yeah hey I just was crossing the
delaware and thought I'd drop by and say
hey right check out my wooden teeth for
all we know spirit that drove George
Washington may be reincarnated in a cat
right now or something like that
you know you don't know maybe our cat
argot a disease worse Washington that
would explain a lot of seeing kind of
like a holographic or representation of
George Washington doing Washington Lee
things Washington so they've had dr.
roll there many many times because they
called him back a couple times because I
think that even though he told them oh
look okay it's either that you guys are
psychic and or that there's this really
high energy field or there's a really
high I feel there's something like that
in your house that's causing
hallucinations and causing other things
of that nature so the family kind of
believed it but didn't seem particularly
comforted by that right because they
think that they had Andy on there saying
like well he seemed like a smart man but
I don't know if that's entirely all that
was going on
yeah you know like he said it like that
so he thought that there was more to it
also I would tend to agree with the guy
maybe because I'm sit there going well
you know if they did get like all
scratched up and stuff like that yeah
maybe they could have been doing that
themselves Johnny from personal exploit
from personal experience if you if you
ever have to do with a poltergeist there
is a feeling of presence yeah there is
the feeling of being watched it's pretty
strong when that thing's really rolling
when a poltergeist outbreak is really
going when it's going strong you're
gonna swear up and down that there's a
damn person yeah an interactive person
in that house maybe one that's not real
friendly yeah it's it's ominous and
creepy very very creepy and that's very
commonly reported and you know you've
seen it here yeah and it can do things
that are kind of creepy but from what
you've seen just nothing compared to
wait yeah cuz I mean what I saw was
strange but it didn't frighten me I
didn't feel like I was in danger I
didn't feel any sense of ominous and no
sense of presence any no I didn't feel a
presence really like I was kind of
creeped out after but I was just like
but I don't think it was just because I
don't think it was because I felt a
presence that was just like would that
was creepy when I was 13 you'd have the
feeling of presence yeah being watched
from the ceiling I've only ever had that
one time it was at my grandmother's
house and I was sitting at the table and
I swear to God I felt someone behind me
yeah like it was really so so much that
I Turner I'm like who is that reason
there was no in there above us like up
towards the ceiling near a corner like
something's up there looking down on you
and murders are and then you wonder how
does a person feel like they're being
watched by what mechanism do you feel
like you're being watched nobody knows
that some of these people have done
experiments and they think s/m do the
quantum consciousness where if you scare
at a person's back for a person's head
they can feel it most of the time they
can tell when someone's looking at that
and evidently women are better at it
than men yes somebody's watching them
well it's that yeah and I'm not nobody
really knows how that happens nothing's
coming out of your eyeballs touching
that person yeah so what is it that's
what I mean that's why I think like some
kind of mild latent psychic ability
isn't that crazy because I mean like
people do know when people are looking
at them even
you're not looking at him and [ __ ] like
that maybe it's just like a heightened
perception
maybe it's the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle how does the subatomic
particle know that it's being measured
yeah similar kind of things probably the
same kind of perception in mind yes but
so the thing is even though you know
William roll had been there and it's
like you know it's nothing to worry
about you guys are just psychic or it's
a natural phenomena or whatever
nothing's going to hurt you and then the
psychic that Amy person that came she
kind of said a similar thing she's like
I do think that there are spirits here
like she thought they were surviving
personalities she thought mr. Gordy was
still there and Khan was still there and
things like that but she said you know
no one's going to hurt you you guys are
just psychic and you're just gonna have
to learn deal with it because you guys
have this gift and ability and you're
always going to see ghosts and things
and just kind of roll with it however
the family didn't like it so they
eventually went to their church for help
and this was probably years later on I
mean because they showed it some on the
show and Heidi was like a teenager she
was like 14 or 15 now I should note too
that after the family were on unsolved
mysteries they didn't mention unsolved
mysteries on the show they said oh a
member of the press came out but I think
this was maybe they weren't allowed for
legal reasons to refer that show or
something but yeah so after the show
about them came out on unsolved
mysteries Heidi was relentlessly bullied
in the town because this is like a small
town right and they said so everybody
just made fun of her and you know she
started taking chest TV I get to be
honest I'm prettier than her but yeah so
that's kind of that was so she got
bullied a lot and stuff like that
and like I said she still continued to
see things much you know much later into
her life you know she even showed her
likes showing the that black figure let
you saw it stand out on the porch and
then it walked through the wall and
stuff like that so they so they went to
the church thinking that well it's
demonic and we have to do something
about it so they had their preacher on
there at camp representing but he was I
called him the preacher meatball because
he was like a
yeah cuz he looked like a big
meatballers no man or something he was
just like a big round body with a little
round head on and he had the patented
southern preacher voice they must all go
to the same place to like learn that yet
because you know them with oil and it
was all that guy said I gotta put a
little bit anyways he's like Moses the
Lord sees about turn to check you missed
your calling
that's a [ __ ] you have the voice down
pat yeah because they like an over and
done see a third over yeah yeah over
enunciate you put vibrato into it yeah
and you turning cos you always sound
like you're just right on the verge of
an emotional breakdown you know what I
mean like spirits coming through a power
the Lord's coming through you and then
more southern than the South itself yeah
yeah you have to southern the [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah so they go to the church you
know it's one of those kind of churches
they get anointed with oil and stuff
like that now evidently
they kind of left the end ambiguous like
I think at the very end of the two-hour
documentary they have him coming back to
the house and then Heidi is kind of like
man I don't know if that really didn't
good but the family said yeah it did you
know
think positive but then they showed like
a shadow in the window like almost like
oh it could still be going on now
evidently from what I've read about the
family subsequently apparently they
eventually did move out of that house
now Heidi grew up and married had kids
and out of normal life and stuff like
that in the in the house they moved to
later I think there was some poltergeist
type activity where like Heidi got
picked up out of her bed and like
dangled by her legs and stuff like that
they didn't really mention that on the
show I just saw that on some other thing
so you know she went on and grew up and
everything like that but she says that
she still sees spirits every now and
then she says she hasn't seen mr. Gordy
for a while probably since she's gonna
teenager I think she when she was
writing she was learning to ride a bike
or she's got a new bike or something
like that mr. Gordy was like hey I'll
help you on your bike and then that was
the last time she ever saw so she didn't
see him again after that so I guess he
thought she didn't need any further
protection she was definitely a medium
yeah that's kind of what the pair of
psychologist did the other psychic
thought they said she was just a natural
medium that she that perhaps it was
genetic because evidently Joyce who is
Lisa's sister Heidi's aunt she said that
their mother had grown up in an even
more rural part of Georgia called
hainted holler yes or continent hated
her hated holler handed or haunted
hollow for those of you not and
evidently it had something to do with
the Trail of Tears and you know there
was a lot of spirits there you can hear
like screaming there were ghosts like
screaming and stuff like yeah coming out
of cave and evidently the grandmother
and maybe I don't know they implied that
Lisa had been born with a veil over her
face which is why they called the book
the veil cuz you know how sometimes
babies will be born with like a film of
skin yeah over their face and back in
middle ages and stuff like that they
thought that if you were born with that
then you had second sight okay so that's
still a very common particularly in the
south that's still a very common old
wives tale if you want to call it that
that you're born with a veil so you can
see the other side or whatever so
evidently the grandmother had been born
with that and the mother and stuff like
that now okay so even though there was
this relationship to the Trail of Tears
and you know the infamous Native
American burial grounds yada yada always
blaming us on Indians I know I wonder if
they get pissed up at that yeah it's
like it wasn't us okay every ghost is an
autos Indians a law for real like we
didn't do it white here we'll just live
with it
ah kids just keep keep your ghost ears
on well they died what everybody died
yeah they're been dead people on every
square foot of America yeah you think
these just be you and you'd be able to
move you'd be like elbow and ghosts out
of the way we're talking about all the
Indians have spirits is another side I
guess no white ghosts we don't have
something without so it's like a red
shed there is that one episode where
what I want to have a haunting episode
where that
black guy that goes to that black guy
was going in there this is my house yeah
I was scare the [ __ ] out of me well yeah
yeah well any ghosts doing that would
[ __ ] this is my house and actor that
they had to yeah yeah so as I mentioned
before they actually made a Hollywood
movie about this case and even though so
you know this this new Decker case was
The Haunting in Connecticut which was
actually kind of a big hit and then they
made the sequel which was called The
Haunting in Connecticut : ghosts of
Georgia
yeah because Connecticut Georgia what's
the diff : something to do with a call
and that's all eyes okay so the weird
thing about the movie and I saw it on
cable I don't even know if it was
released in the theaters or if it was
just like a directed Netflix kind of
deal I saw it it's not terrible but it
wasn't all that great and they really
took some liberties with the case I mean
you know the families their names were
the same they had a thing with mr. Gordy
and stuff like that but for a long time
they kind of made you think that mr.
Gordy was a bad guy like he'd been a
slave master or something I can't
remember all the details yeah didn't
even live during those times well yeah
and that's what's dumb is just like and
I'm like you know mr. Gordy was a real
guy and he probably still has relatives
that alive and they're just like hey
[ __ ] you I mean well I was thinking that
when I was watching it now at the end of
the movie spoiler alert you find out
that mr. Gordy was actually the good guy
along well like he wasn't but for a long
time in the movie you think it's a bad
guy okay even though the kid is saying
it's not a bad guy the momma's like it's
a total bad guy he was the slave master
or whatever but there was all this stuff
about the Underground Railroad and all
these like slaves in the woods that were
like stuff that made into mannequins or
I don't remember what it was
no it was a it was not a ventriloquist
ventriloquist axon terminal Chris
instead taxidermy a taxidermist who
somehow wanted to make slaves into
taxidermy trophies I am for I don't know
why just cuz just because cuz it'll look
good in the movies yes yes
yes oh that is so you know obviously
that had nothing to do with the case
there was nothing to do with slavery it
was nothing to do with anything as far
as I know so uh you know movie it's an
okay movie but it's not although that
one episode with that black ghost man
that did have something due to slavery
we gotta do that too what the name of
that one was yeah evidently he became a
freed slave and the slave owner yeah him
The Prodigy the Denver bomb because you
know the master thought he was the
rightful heir
this guy yeah and then the extended
family came back and took it away from
him that's right member that yeah yeah
and then later on in modern era people
were buying this property and they were
seeing the images of this black ghost
and a pickle hat like a big cowboy hat
bearing down on where they were asleep
this is my house this is my house boy I
know I can't remember with that I don't
know if that's one of the ones that we
have because I don't remember seeing it
recently I don't think we had that one
okay so it must have been Jawaid it must
have been later than season six we need
to get do some of the other seasons yeah
cuz I think I think we have all but all
by all but I think the last season I
have a season six I think that one no
cuz I got you a box set and that has one
through four and then I got you five and
six separately because I don't think
they sell them in box sets anymore or
they didn't when I was looking for those
yeah well I have to buy the the newer
ones because I think they crammed them
all because it every day every now and
then they'll come with a comment with a
real good one and I mean I think we've
seen all of them except for maybe the
super most recent ones but yeah I think
you're still running
yeah as far as I know because there was
a big gap of like several years and then
they were taken over by someone else and
they started making them again like
after destiny yeah I got after they
moved it that's my gotta get the new
ones yeah we should probably get the new
ones cuz I remember some of them being
pretty decent yeah but anyway um oh my
gosh okay so we're at the end of the
show so I guess we will wrap this up we
pretty much got to the end of it anyway
yeah is there anything to this case I
think so
probably it just seems like a too much
of a I mean they didn't super exaggerate
a lot of stuff there wasn't like a lot
of poltergeist activity or anything like
that going on you had a good pair of
psychologists involved yeah a lot of
witnesses the claims are not real
outlandish when you really get down to
them not really they brought a psychic
in on the case that I usually don't like
to bring in psychics on a case because
they tend to muddy the waters but she
didn't say anything
was too she didn't say anything crazy
order to stay better or anything right
but something happened yeah probably
probably something happened I I would
think I think the most compelling part
of the story is that she could pick mr.
Gordy up out of a lineup she identified
long yeah as mr. Kong knew where the
grave was even before she could read I
think those were some of the strongest
points of the case yeah because that's
pretty weird
and I mean if it went down the way they
said it did that's consistent room
that's pretty kind of hard evidence if
it really happened I'm not there they're
saying that that happened like I said it
says with everything you're kind of one
person removal you're one person removed
let's give him the benefit of the doubt
you say that okay and like you said
they're not saying anything for not
written landish enough and also here's
another thing there is no cohesive plot
to this yeah because there's no cohesive
plot and there's no motive you know to
the story I tend to believe it because I
think that the real cases tend to be
kind of random yeah random in vague
that's why and you know later of
phenomena just happening like I said and
it did seem like that too like when I
was researching the unseen hand it
seemed like a lot of the cases that
seemed like they probably happened the
way the witnesses said there was no
story to it there is no three-act plot
it was just random [ __ ] yeah it didn't
mean anything
right and it didn't happen in any
particular path new land deeds didn't
have nothing to do with vengeance from
the grave or any of the other compelling
plot devices that drive a ghost yeah
which I can see why they do that for the
movies cuz you know it's a movie and
it's supposed to be exciting and stuff
like that and a lot of times real
quote-unquote real paranormal cases
don't really lend themselves to that
type of plot structure for years after
the poltergeist episode that my family
went through I I asked myself over and
over now why did that happen what did
that mean
who was that you know yeah it was never
really a question you'll never figure it
out yeah I don't because I don't think
it's any intelligent no intelligence
causing it not really not not the
traditional sense of the word yeah
no I think it's right hemisphere brain
activity linked with psychic abilities
meat and mediumistic abilities yes so
you're almost getting kind of a weird
dreamlike sort of logic recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis you know an
emotional it's emotionally driven
logically or not logically driven and
not driven by a store like by a horror
narrative out of a out of a book you
know it's not like yeah yeah it's just
you're feeling bad and bad [ __ ] happens
you're feeling tense things move yeah
it's just that and like I said it's a
sleeper meaning seems like a similar
kind of thing here it just seems like a
case of family members that seem
particularly sensitive to the past in a
particular area and were either you know
creating these apparitions or were
seeing them in their minds eye when it
was happened to me if I was a kid if
somebody came up to me and said hey
touch this object you know where this
came from I maybe I could say yeah I
might have been able to answer yeah yeah
I know who I know where this is bad no
one ever came at me with those kind of
tasks yes because evidently they came in
in the in field case they came at they
came at Janet with a spoon and she bent
it by looking at it she didn't even have
to rub it like a regular a lot of times
a lot of times when you have a kid who's
going through this they can do things
that they haven't even imagined probably
a good idea to go in there Challenger
where is your sister right now she might
be able to tell you yes you can see what
their parameters of the abilities yeah
that might be an interesting thing to
investigate right but you could put a
piece of paper inside of a plastic boxes
is it well can you make that catch on
fire or can the ghosts make that catch
on fire yeah and see if they you know if
cyclic an or if pyrokinesis happens yeah
a [ __ ] it would I think we're gonna do
a show on pyrokinesis in a new episodes
because someone recommended we do a
kaneto that's out in Italy that all fire
started everywhere and I actually put it
my book and I said yeah we should
probably do a show about that because
that's kind of a really that's a really
weird thing that IRA Kinesis is modified
telekinesis it's the same thing you just
move molecules yeah see that's kind of
how I feel about you okay anyway so
we've reached the end of the show hope
you enjoyed our again a rambling
discussion of me a haunting episode in
this case the pilot episode of the
famous mr. Gordy and me being a mush
mouth and no you're right as always if
you like the show please Like us on
Facebook please share the show on all
your social media please subscribe to
our YouTube channel
and please give us a follow on twitter
also also if you didn't notice we did
another movie review Conan the Barbarian
come and asked 1000 subs we did we
forgot to mention that forgot the match
so woohoo and thanks everybody so seems
to be getting bigger yeah and we hope to
be able to keep doing it as long as
we're able to do it yeah
also if as long as there's demand and
long as their support will continue as
long as everyone's not sick of us even
if they are sick of us I don't care I do
it anyway but yeah so um also if you
would like to support the show remember
to visit our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
mike share subscribe yes I said that
already
ok and I'm also checking on the same
also check out zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock where we have some shirts and
don't forget if you want to contribute a
scary personal experience or scary
personal story to our Halloween episode
and we might feature it on there then
please contact me on Facebook and I'll
give you the email address or it will be
in the description its grave cake at
gmail.com just send me one and if we
pick it we will read it and/or summarize
that on the air and oo also next week's
show I think I'm going to on the YouTube
video I'm going to premiere the little
commercial I made for my new true crime
book so ok so have a look out for that
IB it should be on next week's episode
we'll see how it goes and other than
that that'll do it for episode 59 see
you next Tuesday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you